وضع هذا الفيديو حديقة حيوان في الصين في مأزق
عندما انفجرت وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي الصينية
بادعاءات أن هذا الحيوان كان إنسانًا يرتدي
زيًا، فقررت حديقة الحيوان أن تبتسم وتتحمل،
فأصدرت بيانًا بصوت
الحيوان يقول أنا دب الشمس
رسالة رددتها حديقة حيوان أخرى في المملكة المتحدة،
هل شاهدت هذا الفيديو
نعم لقد رأيت هذا الفيديو وأنا
مقتنع جدًا جدًا 100 متأكد أنه يوم أحد
هو عالم أحياء ومؤسس
مركز الحفاظ على دب الشمس البورني،
هذه وجبة
نحن  أحضر جو هنا وأعتقد أنه يمكننا أن
نقول بثقة أن هذا دب وليس
إنسانًا يرتدي زيًا، نعم هذا دب،
هذه الغابة المسيجة في
بورنيو الماليزية تؤوي 44 دب شمس تم إنقاذهم،
إنهم أصغر دب في العالم،
يبدو مشابهًا جدًا له  الناس عندما
يقفون،
تعتبر دب الشمس أيضًا من الأنواع المهددة بالانقراض، حيث
تتقلص موطنها في الغابات الاستوائية عبر جنوب شرق آسيا. كيف
يبدو المستقبل بالنسبة لدب الشمس
كنوع في البرية في الوقت الحالي،
الغابة ليست كبيرة بما يكفي لا يزال صيد حواء
والصيد غير المشروع  استمر، المستقبل
كبير جدًا ليوم الأحد لأنهم
بحاجة إلى غابات كبيرة من أجل البقاء على قيد الحياة.
يقول أحدهم أن هناك سوقًا غير قانوني لأسنان
ومخالب دب الشمس والأعضاء المستخدمة في
الطب الآسيوي التقليدي.
الآن الفيديو الصيني الفيروسي يمنح
أصغر دب في العالم لحظة
الشمس في الأيام الأخيرة ارتفعت بنسبة
30 بالمائة في حديقة الحيوان في هانغتشو،
ولا تبدو رطبة على الإطلاق عندما
تراها شخصيًا، يقول هذا الرجل شيئًا
يجب أن تضعه في الاعتبار في المرة القادمة التي يتم فيها
إرسال مقطع فيديو سريع الانتشار إليك إيفان واتسون سي إن إن هونغ
كونغ